the official Christmas tree in Rome is
getting a lot of attention this morning
for its very sickly look never good when
you're talking about a Christmas tree
right critics are now questioning the
70-foot fir trees large price tag Seth
Doane is in Rome at the Piazza Venezia
where the tree is losing needles very
fast Seth good morning good morning yes
Rome is decked out for the holidays with
lights and decorations everywhere but at
the center of it all in this rather
magnificent location is that rather sad
tree brought in from North Italy Romans
who have a knack for giving a good
nickname call its Bellagio which in
Italian means mangy threadbare or
balding and there it stands barely
looking a little like a tree the
neighbors should have taken down weeks
ago
do you wanna Jose de gallo told us it's
indicative of some of Italy's problems I
think that is dead and is very sad
satury yeah yes it's very sad tree and
the problem is that they is worldwide
now everybody knows about everybody yes
Palacio has been ridiculed here and
bullied online one internet user likened
it to a toilet brush now the tree has a
Twitter account handle at Spa Keo with
more than 4000 followers and when
compared with trees and say Washington
DC or New York City well it is a tad
reminiscent of this as if to rub it in
just down the street the Vatican has a
spectacular tree in front of st. Peter's
this is kind of like coming to a
cemetery
Fabricio dipascali brought a bouquet of
flowers today for poor spell akia
perhaps or something
wrong on the transportation or I don't
know the city of Rome paid more than
$55,000 for the trees delivery and
disposal and officially hasn't said
anything about the controversy still
some see an elegance to it with its 600
silver balls this mother and daughter
from Australia were surprised to learn
of all the fuss
maybe Romans left to be passionate about
most things and that's just another
thing to be passionate about was it
abused was it poison social media users
are demanding answers and some Noora are
calling for a funeral
I learned from a Charlie Brown Christmas
that every tree needs love right that's
not what you learn yes that's the
Christmas I don't want a tree that looks
like a toilet brush I will set my
brought that tree home my kids would
fire me that's right yeah good report
thank you sir